did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV ton appears on sensored Israeli PM
Benjamin Netanyahu rejects a masses
proposed ceasefire which would have seen
all Israel hostages freed he says total
Victory is months away but critics say
months is a death sentence for tens of
thousands more Palestinians and
potentially the Israeli hostages too
Prince William gets back to World duties
as Prince Harry heads back home to Los
Angeles should the feuding Brothers have
made amends after the king's cancer
diagnosis so is Prince William basically
done with his little
brother President Biden tells crowns he
recently spoke to a French president who
died in 1996 before forgetting the name
of Hamas what is happening to the
president of the United
States live from the new news building
in London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to Pi Morgan uncensored it was a
safest B of the week wasn't it or maybe
the second safest the fiori about rishy
sunak 1,000 wager with me seemed like
perfect fodder for prime minister's
questions and S starma took about two
seconds to cash
in Mr Speaker a year ago the Prime
Minister promised to bring NHS waiting
list down isn't he glad he didn't better
a grand on
it Minister Mr
[Applause]
Speaker Mr Speaker Mr Speaker at least I
stand by my
commitments he he he's so he's so
indecisive the only bet heed makers in
each way
bet well quite clearly the standard the
British parliamentary banter has slumped
in historic low on a much more serious
note so is the National Health Service
our leaders were debating starmer again
referenced the prime minister's
unsensored interview when he said this I
welcome the fact that he's finally
admitted that he's failed on waiting
lists in the NHS well he has admitted it
to me and this was the moment he did so
NHS waiting list we have not made enough
progress you failed on that Pledge yes
because you said any waiting this will
fall uh in fact they are slightly coming
down now but the waiting still nearly
half a million more than it was at the
start of last year you accept that yes
and we all know the reasons for that and
what I would say to people is look we've
invested record amounts in the NHS more
doctors more nurses more scanners all
these things mean that the NHS is doing
more today than it ever has been but
industrial action has had an impact well
lot's been said and written this week
about that charity bet we made in that
interview some of it's been frankly
ridiculous but to me the prime
minister's a mission that his government
has failed on NHS waiting list and in
the state of A&E was much more
significant and well a lot more personal
so my mother is 79 and she had a heart
attack three months ago she was put on a
trolley in A&E in a corridor for nearly
hours the heart monitor battery ran out
nobody fixed it at one stage no nurse
came for 3 or 4 hours there were between
she reckons 35 and 40 other people
people on trolleys in the corridors and
she was also terrified of course having
been told you've had a heart attack that
no one was putting her into the unit and
actually trying to fix her now once she
got up there the treatment she got was
world class she was fixed within 36
hours but I you know I brought this one
picture to show you that's you know
that's my mom who's worked all her life
right paid her taxes all her life and
when she really needed the NHS yeah
eventually then HS came through but she
could have died on that trolley and I
think that's
shocking well a couple of things have
happened since I shared that story with
the Prime Minister first as I said last
night he had the courtesy and good grace
to send my mother a bunch of flowers and
then he called her had a 10-minute
conversation and she was very impressed
by the fact he took time to do that and
by what he said about what he hopes to
do with the NHS whilst accepting it's in
one hell of a mess uh and I appreciate
it but secondly a viewer wrote to me
after seeing the interview with a story
that was awful horribly familiar and
frankly quite disturbing I'm going to
read part of it it said my Mom was
admitted to hospital with dangerously
low blood oxygen levels on Friday
lunchtime this is last week my dad
experienced similar concerns about her
care that you shared she was still in
A&E on Saturday in a crowded Corridor my
dad 80 years old was concerned that her
oxygen levels were too low her oxygen
canister wasn't being checked
she was originally given an empty
canister despite her reason for
admission her alarms were not being
responded to he found it so distressing
he left the hospital rather than create
conflict in trusting my mother to their
care well my mother sadly passed on
Saturday evening while still in accident
emergency more than 24 hours after
arrival it's a truly shocking story
isn't it and here's the other shocking
twist it was exactly the same A&E
department where my my mother had been
just 3 months ago now that is not an
exception that's pretty much the rule
now in A&E departments up and down the
country and I don't blame the staff
there aren't enough of them the ones
that are there are overworked underpaid
undervalued and completely beleaguered
but there are people literally dying
after waiting 24 hours on trolleys in
A&E this country in modern Britain and
honestly I find that completely and
utterly shaming to the
country well my friend Jeremy bow at the
BBC yesterday shared this picture of his
86 year old mother who was advised to go
to hospital by her doctor and spent the
entire night sitting on a hard plastic
chair while she waited for somebody to
see her our doctors and nurses they're
working flat out and the system is
completely broken and often now feels
well incapable of providing even basic
care like treating elderly people when
the come to A&E and they're nearly dying
they should be the priority not the
afterthought We Love Our National Health
Service with good reason when it works
it's fantastic but when it doesn't work
as is increasingly the case it's a
disaster and frankly shame on our
leaders for bickering about it while it
crumbles after many many administrations
from left and right have failed it we'll
debate all that in a moment but first
there breaking news an hour before I
came on air that Benjamin Netanyahu has
categorically dismissed hamas's new
calls for a prolonged ceasefire in Gaza
pledging to forge a hair with Israel's
military campaign until securing what he
terms as total Victory Netanyahu pledged
to destroy Hamas and ruled out any
Arrangement that leaves a Palestinian
militant group in full or partial
control of Gaza I would like to
emphasize once again there is no other
solution other than this complete and
decisive victory
because otherwise it is just a matter of
time till the next Massacre and the
access of Terror from Iran will continue
so only by destroying Hamas will we have
security for the state of Israel in the
north and in the South because Hamas
would like to radiate its Terror all
over the Middle
East what you may discussed this is the
Israeli American journalist Trader the
Israeli American activist and author mik
pelled and the Palestinian commentator
Omar bad well welcome to all of you um
start with you Emily uh a lot of people
around the world imploring Israel to
have some kind of ceasefire not least to
get the hostages are but also to stop
the Relentless killing of uh innocent
Palestinians women children and so on
but Netanyahu absolutely adamant tonight
no deal no ceasefire we will go on until
Hamas are completely finished what is
your reaction to
this well first of all thanks for having
me on this important topic tonight I
think the way that even the sentiment
was phrased that it's Israel rejecting
ceasefire isn't quite accurate you know
when it comes to what the situation is
on the ground Israel has been willing to
accept multiple ceasefires in the past
as well as they have done temporary
pauses in fighting um the reality is
that we had a ceasefire on October 6th
it wasn't Israel who started this War um
but it is Israel who will finish it and
you cannot invade The Sovereign borders
we're not even talking about disputed
territory we're not talking about the
West Bank but the Sovereign borders of
the state of Israel rape murder and maim
innocent people and then kidnap over 200
more and expect that you can dictate the
terms of your own Survival and staying
in power in the Gaza Strip This is just
not the way it works and Israel would
actually be in violation of
international law for doing so because
Israel as a state Act has an obligation
legally to restore a sense of security
to the citizens of the state of Israel
and unfortunately that cannot be done
until Hamas is removed from power in the
Gaza Strip well mik I can see you
laughing there incredulously before you
respond to that I just want to inform
viewers about what the Hamas proposed
deal was as seen by the Reuters news
agency phase one a 45-day pause in
fighting during which all Israeli women
hostages is males under 19 the elderly
and sick will be exchanged for
Palestinian women and children held in
Israeli jails Israeli forces would
withdraw from populated areas of Gaza
and the Reconstruction of hospitals and
refugee camps would begin phase two
remaining male Israeli hostages would be
exchanged for Palestinian prisoners and
Israeli forces would leave Gaza
completely phase three both sides would
exchange remains and bodies and Hamas is
also calling for the complete withdrawal
of Israeli forces from Gaza going
forward um your response to Netanyahu
saying No
Deal oh mik mik I'm sorry I think you're
muting you're on mute at the moment if
you wouldn't mind just unmuting yourself
yes you're back well it seem it seems
certainly that the Hamas proposal is
reasonable that netan being a genocidal
Maniac who wants to continue the killing
and the Bloodshed is not interested I
mean I think we've seen that the last
several months of of of his policies in
Gaza have led to what can only be
described as mass genocide and since the
entire world is standing with him and
he's not seeing any he's not facing any
consequences seriously there's no reason
for him to stop and so the question is
will the International Community step in
and force him to stop the killing force
him to accept the Hamas or the the
Palestinian proposals uh and will the
International Community stand by the the
Palestinians who are now like I said
presented uh the world and presented
Israel with a very reasonable um a very
reasonable proposal for ceasefire having
said that I think the ceasefire is
nowhere nearly enough I think I think
the entire International Community needs
to come in and and declare a no fly zone
over Gaza and and impose severe
sanctions against the state of Israel
particularly now since it's obvious that
he's the is the state of Israel is
refusing even a very reasonable proposal
by uh by the Palestinians by the pal
representatives in in the Gaza Strip so
it seems very very clear the only
question is why is the International
Community not standing with the
Palestinians and not helping the
Palestinians to enforce at least this
very reasonable um proposal okay but to
play devil's advocate here Israel's
position is that Hamas committed an
appalling terror attack on October the
7th killing over 1,200 people uh many of
whom were innocent women and children
butchered in the most Savage Manner and
they have publicly stated since then
Hamas that they will do the same thing
again and again and again if they're
able to and at the moment depending on
which figures you you look at at least
half the Hamas fighting force is still
there and still fighting um representing
to Israelis an existential threat to
their very existence so why should
Netanyahu in that circumstance allow
half of Hamas to continue to exist and
present that threat to his
people well the question is why why
we're accepting the the Israeli premise
to this Israel has been engaged in
genocide and apartheid policies for 75
years Palestinians have been living
under a reign of terror particularly in
the Gaza Strip this is not the first
time that Israel massacred civilians by
the thousands in the Gaza Strip so why
Palestinians are resisting and why
Palestinian Fighters came out of Gaza on
October 7th and and and engaged in
resistance is not the question there not
resistance is it
what is what is resistance about raping
and murdering and kidnapping innocent
civilian
resoc
murdering murdering children the stre no
right to talk about killing children
Israel has no right to talk exist in the
first place Israel you believe that
Israel has a right to exist in the first
Israel has been massacring children you
right hang let me to talk about theill
let me inter
inter let me interrupt
because pleas with respect Mr P let me
interrupt to say one member of the panel
hasn't spoken yet and has kept very
quiet respectfully during that uh
exchange between the two of you Omar
badan this this cuts to the quick of the
story really if you view what Hamas did
on October the 7th as simply
resistance then to me you are ignoring
the reality that it was an apping terror
attack you can have absolutely
legitimate concerns about the scale of
Israel's response I have them myself but
do you genuinely also believe that it
was resistance what happened that day
I'll I'll get to that in a minute but I
do have to respond first to the Gaul of
somebody invoking the killing of
children in light of Israel having
killed nearly 12,000 pal Palestinian
children buried under the rubble over
the past three months in a genocidal
scale in violence against against
defenseless children it's is utterly and
completely absurd and the second and
equally important point to make is that
anybody who tells you that there was a
ceasefire on October 6th was lying to
you on October 6 Palestinians had no
Freedom whatsoever throughout the Gaza
Strip they could not go in and out of
Gaza no airport no sea port no jobs no
access to the outside world no
functioning electricity and Israel
continued to steal Palestinian land in
the West Bank throughout that entire
year and for decades frankly even before
that and had killed nearly 250
Palestinians in the course of just the
beginning of the year until October 6th
so people who call that a ceasefire are
basically telling you to accept a status
quo in which Palestinians can be
murdered they can have their children
thrown in military detention
indefinitely in which Palestinian land
can be taken away from them at will and
they can be denied freedom and that's an
acceptable status quo so long as
Israelis are safe there's a word for
that kind of world and that's called
apartheid that is the current status quo
that always existed leading up to the
that we saw on October 7th now certainly
anytime that you engage in violence
against civilians that is completely
indefensible and there's no way to
excuse that nonetheless thinking people
look at the situation that led up to it
and understand that imprisoning
Palestinians by the Millions for no
crime other than being Palestinian in
Gaza and allowing and denying them
access to the outside world uh is
essentially a recipe to create a wave of
violence that is effectively inevitable
people who are serious about wanting to
end violence and serious about producing
a situation in which there is peace for
both Israelis and Palestinians have to
be concerned about the driving force of
that violence and the driving force is
absolutely Israeli apartheid that has
denied Palestinians freedom for too long
and until you solve that underlying
problem you're never going to get into a
situation in which there is any safety
or security for any you know you
continue you continue using all these
buzzword aarth genocide and those aren't
what those words actually mean but I do
want to clarify a few things that you
commented on the
I shouldn't be speaking about killing
children there is a massive difference
between a defensive War targeting
terrorist targets that are using
civilian fights including un schools
including hospitals IND dangering their
own people in the Gaza Strip something
that they themselves have admitted and
the invading of The Sovereign borders of
a foreign country and murdering children
in their home on let me ask question
not a defensive
War let let me ask Emily a question and
it's this Emily look I think Israel had
a right to defend itself a duty to
defend itself but we now have as we've
heard I think it's 12,000 children
believed to have been killed uh another
20,000 or so have been orphaned uh
2third of Gaza has been flattened and
here Benjamin Netanyahu says after four
months well we're nowhere near finished
there's months more of this we will
continue until the last Hamas terrorist
is gone okay but that may mean the
entire Gaza Strip is gone destroyed
flattened it may mean well hang on it
may mean the number of children killed
doubles to 20,000 maybe 30,000 at what
point does this become even to people
who support Israel imp pla about this
does it become just utterly
disproportionate well I think
proportionality isn't the actual
question here there's a very easy way to
end this war and that is to return all
of the hostages and to surrender
unconditionally that is what hamash
should be doing that is where the
focus hang on Emily that
would no hang on Benjamin Netanyahu
stated unequivocally this goes on until
Hamas are finished all of them that
means another that means another 20,000
people have to be killed right who are
just the terrorists so he's not going to
stop if the hostages got released
tomorrow that's not true I said unal
uncal of Hamas I don't think Prim
Minister Netanyahu has any intention
even if the hostages get returned
tomorrow of letting 20,000 Hamas
terrorists remain in power in Gaza he's
going to continue but that's I already
said that I said the release of hostages
and the unconditional surrender of Hamas
Hamas cannot remain in power in the Gaza
Strip and restore have Israel restore a
sense of security those two things
cannot coexist that is why Netanyahu
said we will not accept any term in
which Hamas stays in power because they
will do the same thing again and the
longer this goes on the longer they stay
in power the more funding I think the
most recent documents said 150 million
went through senoir in the documents
that the
ID the more money that Iran is funding
you canot just stronger Hamas is you
cannot just kill everybody in Gaza you
can't Israel is not intending to kill
everyone in Gaza
they carry on for many more months they
carry on for many more months how many
people are going to get killed no I
can't answer that question as to how
many people are going to be killed but I
can tell you that not a single uh not
even one more person would be killed if
Hamas surrendered unconditionally
today can I suggest something I make a
suggestion since nahu and his government
have before October 7th have already and
and previous Israeli government have
murdered more civilians than Hamas ever
did why don't we do why don't we flip
this equation and say that the hostages
will be released once Nano and his
government are taken to the ha and and
and uh and charged with war crimes I
think it makes much more sense the
Israelis have killed far more
Palestinian children and Palestinian
civilians than Hamas or any Palestinians
ever have Israeli attacks on Gaza
preceded Hamas by decades Israeli
attacks the West Bank go on Israeli
attacks in Jerusalem go on where Hamas
is not in charge so I mean this whole
Hamas excuse is ridiculous why we do
this let's wait till let's wait till we
remove nany's government and then
negotiate I think that should be the
condition and the Israeli military which
is a genocidal terrorist organization is
disarmed and dismantled that will be a
good time okay let me let me final let
me give the final word to the
Palestinian on the panel which is you
Omar look we have to be stop this
pretense that Israel is engaging in
accidental violence in which Palestinian
civilians are killed every major human
rights organization in the world
including by the way Israeli human
rights organizations document that the
Israeli military is engaging in
indiscriminate violence against
civilians and that is why the
international court of justice has found
that there is actually a plausible Case
for Israel being engaged in genocidal
violence in Gaza and that should tell
you something and we have to stop
pretending that you can kill this many
people on accident and just one issue
with with something that you mentioned
Piers I don't think this is a question
of proportionality we have to be clear
about what Israel is doing here this is
not an act of self-defense because an
occupier can never in principle be
defending themselves against the people
they're occupying if we are serious once
again what Israel is doing in Gaza if
they wanted self-defense there were zero
there were zero Israelis in Gaza on
October 6
zero Gaza they bombed it at will
whenever they wanted to and they
prevented you never mention EGP no
responsibility
everything is always Israel you you know
the problem the problem with that
argument the problem with that argument
is this is that when it wanted to at the
start of this war Israel had the power
and capability to turn off the energy
into Gaza to turn off the internet to
turn off the water to turn off the food
supply that is a form of occupation even
if you're not physically inside Gaza
that's actually false
Def
of I don't think Israel should have that
power over any Palestinian if Israel if
Israel was interested terorist
organization should be ruling
Palestinians either I don't think that I
agree with you is ring Israel I agree
with you I agree with you nuclear poers
ruling is okay listen I've got to bring
it I've got to bring it to an end it was
a good it was a good debate thank you
I've got to leave it there I'm sorry
we've run out of time we've gone longer
than than I was expecting to I
appreciate the passion on all sides I
hope we can get to a point where this
ends and and people stop dying I think
we can all agree with that so thank you
all of you for joining me I appreciate
it on says next prime minister richy
sunx in hot water for what's been called
a transphobic joke at secure starmer's
expense well we'll debate it
next hey very good morning to you thanks
for joining us you're with talk TV on TV
on radio online and on your smart
speaking good morning Rosie good morning
Nick we're here in turnworth for you to
find out exactly why some people are
traveling halfway around the world and
queuing for hours for one of these The
Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't
sense this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
a hatchet and what a sword and a knife
how is that even technically
possible we going on the
show it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by St
KH the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great May
sadique KH brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to rishy sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with that
Donald Trump didn't just win he oblit
ated this is a guy facing nearly a 100
criminal charges and yet all that's done
is actually make him more popular Trump
is canny enough to know that all
publicity is good publicity I don't want
a president who's been impeached if he's
able to bamboozle you or that's the wake
it up did my 6 months I came back nobody
would touch me I put my head down and
persisted and carried on when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine actually not my
job to answer your questions I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
welcome back I'm joined by my well super
pack tonight talk to you contribut to
Esther craer the comedian podcaster
James Bar the political journalist avav
Santina from the United States the
YouTuber H Davis well welcome to all of
you so I want to start with this uh big
fiori in the House of Commons today
because well it was basically all about
this show in a way because K stama
opened up by attacking the Prime
Minister about hision
to me that they failed to hit their
waiting L targets and then he went on to
mock him about the bet that we made for
charity over the Rwanda plan um but then
things turned what many think to be
quite ugly because the Prime Minister
said this and it's a bit Rich Mr Speaker
to hear about promises from someone
who's broken every single promise he was
elected on I mean I think I counted
almost 30 in the last year pensions
planning peerages public sector pay
tuition fees Child Care second
referendums defining a woman although
although In fairness that was only 99%
of a U-turn up all the weeks to say that
when briana's mother is in this
chamber
shame parading as a man of integrity
when he's got absolutely no
responsibility well the contentious
element of that is of course that
Brianna J's mother Esther was up in the
gallery now it turned out she wasn't
there actually at the moment that this
joke was made by the Prime Minister he
would say a pointed remark making a
point at Kia st's expense but AA it's
caused a lot of furor this falling out
saying that it was very callous
inappropriate and so on what's your
view I I'm I'm really upset about it I'm
sad I'm sad for her mother and I'm sad
for every trans person in this country
that had to witness that today I think
the for those who don't know her mother
was a transgender girl who was brutally
killed by two complete psychos and it
was her daughter Bri yes Brianna J was
yes was killed and she was she was a
transom um but you know what's really
upsetting about this is that we don't
even afford trans people dignity in
death I think that the way that that is
going to now be marked in Hansard in the
Parliamentary book forever I think that
is shame on the country I'm sad to hear
it James yeah I agree I think it's
utterly shameful just disgusting I'm so
annoyed with Rashi Sak he has absolutely
no Backbone in the same week that he
made a lazy bet with the devil about
refugees he's now devil now made a joke
exactly he's now made a joke about
another minority and it's just
disgusting well okay you're not calling
me the devil uh for one I don't have
horns um but secondly um I don't know
Esther I think I'm missing something I
think the thing is can we get some
perspective here Richie sunak has made
this comment about Kama being unable to
define a woman many times and the only
to be clear about the background to that
Kama spent most of the last two
years refusing to say what a woman then
eventually saying women could have
penises then he said well actually
99% don't have a penis meaning that 1%
do and the one time that he chooses to
defend himself or is himself on his
record is the unfortunate time that
Brianna ji's mother is in is in the
comment I'm sorry look it was in poor
taste given the circumstances but at the
end of the day it's a very valid point
hor something it's a very valid point
because it's a very valid point because
the thing is this whole issue about you
know trans rights doesn't just you know
it's not based on one thing it's also
based on women feeling their like their
right
of no but that's the point that's being
made these are
politicians issues talk about we'
Westminster and gossip Fest nobody is
disputing that trans people have rights
to fairness and equality yes they are no
they're not here's what I'm disputing
I'm sorry but it's 100% of women do not
have a penis let's just start with a
biological fact can you imagine this was
not an attack on this poor woman who
lost her daughter had nothing to do with
her whatsoever this was an attack on K's
inability to actually stand up for
women's rights and to say unequivocally
that women do not have a penis which by
the way is a fact it is standing up for
women's right the moment you trying to
pretend women have a penis you are
destroying women's rights that's women
no they're not okay and I'm sorry unless
you are I F having your skull woman a
biological female you not understand it
I'm sorry unless you're you're someone
who's who who's having your child having
to sh your female child having to share
a bathroom with a biological man you
will never understand what it means for
us to sit there and pretend like trans
you're drill it
down women that have had hysterectomies
are they no longer women let me bring in
P I'm going to bring in P be waiting
patiently Pearl across the pond um a lot
of people clutching their pearls about
all this Pearl ironically but I just
think that in the end what rishy sunak
did was in a list of things that he
claimed his opponent had made u-turns on
he made the completely valid point if
you take it in its in its isolation that
actually it was ridiculous to pretend
that a percentage of women have a penis
and for that he's now being branded
transphobic what do you think of that
well number one I can't believe you guys
are grown adults arguing about what a
woman is or like I it blows my mind
number two um I have family members that
died of obesity I still support people's
right to make jokes about being fat life
is hard get over it and number three um
you know I'm a semi-pro athlete here in
in the UK you know I I I play I play
sports in London
and I've actually had to deal with some
of the consequences of women being
women's spaces
being you know having men come in them
and like you know I had a tournament
last spring where there was a whole team
full of men you know just dressed up as
women so is that
fair I think i' be more threatened by
your your your recent tweet where you
said that 16-year-old girls were hotter
than 26 year-old women if I was a woman
and I saw that tweet and I saw you in a
space I'd be ter
then why aren't you why aren't you
protesting why aren't you protesting the
age of consent laws in the UK if you're
really outraged all all you guys do is
try to find one thing out of context and
you're changing the subject really when
we're here to talk about that is it all
right for him to make jokes people can
make jokes he certainly wasn't here's
the point here's the point he certainly
wasn't trying to make a joke at the
expense of this poor girl who got
murdered or with her mother there
deliberately trying to uh score some
point with her there he was purely
making the point which he's made
repeatedly that when Kia starma can't
say what a woman is that is ridiculous
and I agree with him about that and I'm
not sure that the Prime Minister should
be branded transphobic for not thinking
that a woman has a penis well why do you
think that would you not think that all
of this narrative feeds into the hate
that is in this country absolutely not
think that because it's not
hateful people where do you
I have always supported for example
trans people's rights to fairness
equality always right I've been
repeatedly called transphobic myself for
thinking that a 6 foot4 biological male
who becomes a transwoman athlete and
starts demolishing biological females in
a swimming pool and breaks all records
or wants to be on the Olympic team
depriving a woman of a place and so on
that I think that is ridiculous
transphobic think I'm supporting and
defending women's rights similarly Richi
sunak thinks it is absurd that a
political leader in this country should
think that a any
woman can can I to you that it's quite
possible that Rishi suak is a terrible
politician and he didn't even understand
the
attack that was given to him half of his
party didn't understand it KY badok said
this every murder is a tragedy we can
all agree none should be trivialized by
political Point scoring as a mother I
can imagine the trauma that es guy has
endured it' be shameful of starma to
link his own inability to be clear on on
the matter of sex and gender directly to
her G and that's that's the point here's
here's the issue we have turned
Westminster into a gossip Fest because
Rishi sunak has made this point about K
st's inability to talk about what a
woman is for literally months and we all
understood it but suddenly when there's
an opportunity to score cheap political
points and to make the link between that
and this poor lady Brianna ji's mother
suddenly were now all outraged by this
is not the first time R she I said it
and we know it but because we've decided
to turn our politicians from from actual
politicians who have a job to do to
basically reality stars we we're figing
ignorance over the real issue and that's
well it's a bit like it's a bit to be
honest it's a bit like the BET which you
said was with the devil all right haha
maybe I should get all hurt and upset
about you calling me the devil my
sensitive Little Skin can't deal with
you're not a minority you're likening me
to the most evil creature ever created
I'm so distressed Jes I I want to burst
into tears and take you to some Human
Resources committee meeting not right I
don't care you can have a laugh at my
expense it's is fine we used to be a to
do it and get away with it without being
arrested uh I am a minority I'm a
middle-aged white still on TV many prime
minister they have an effect on real
people yes they do but only when you
deliberately wrongly disingenuously
conflate two completely different things
then they do also I think it's very odd
that tweet from kemy where she's saying
it's wrong to make jokes about murders
but you can clearly make jokes and score
political points about Minor she said
it's unfair it's not right it's immoral
to draw a link between a point that
rishy sunuk has made for literally
months and then to try and Link that
because the fact that Ban's mother she
has some nerve and she's the one who
introduce the trans guidance in December
which means being a
politian we've got to bring an end to
this part of the debate you guys are all
staying to for the next segment where
we're going to talk about something less
contentious the royal family um but just
for the record just for the record if
from my position is is with the Prime
Minister if you are a woman you do not
have a penis that's it doesn't make you
trans phobic and trans women deserve
absolute rights to fairness and equality
right to the point they want to erode
the rights of being a woman sorry that's
just what I feel let's go to the out
let's go to
[Music]
the we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know I love about to today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any e will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pant there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
question are you prepared to call teror
group is it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
welome back to on S Prince Harry has
swiftly retreated back to California
just a day he spent in the UK he had one
well apparently 30 minute meeting
possibly a little longer with the king
at Clarence house after his cancer
diagnosis was revealed this week Harry
did not meet his brother Prince William
he wanted to make that quite clear he
had no intention of meeting him and
tonight William returned to Royal duties
he spent this morning at winter castle
dispensing 50 honors uh and tonight he
was at a charity event where uh Tom Cruz
turned up and the pair of them were
parading for the cameras so quite
exciting evening there um to discuss the
Royals my pack is still with me um let
me start with you Pearl about this uh
given that Harry is fleeing back to your
country where you are now uh at a rate
of knots across the Atlantic are you
pleased that he's on his way back to you
would you like to keep him
there um well not particularly what one
thing I've noticed being in in London
and America and going in between um he's
not really liked in either country and I
think you know life comes with choices
and trade-offs and he made the choice to
trash his family and I I do think it's
going to be tough for him to really get
in the position he was in before um I I
don't know how kind I would be to
someone that trashed my entire family I
know I know exactly even if I was
related to them yeah I know how kind I'd
be I've actually written about this for
the New York Post uh tonight I mean
James what I would do if one of my
family one of my siblings has spent the
last few years trashing the family on
television trash my wife trash my dad's
wife trash my dad trash my sister and so
on I would dismember them one limit of
time um and after they i' severed all
their limbs I would probably incinerate
them I think that's disgusting I know
but that's talking about King Charles
who has cancer right now how can you be
surprised I'm the devil that's what
Devils do what Devils do here's my point
uh I mean metaphorically right what I
mean is I would be utterly ation about
Harry who wrote a book a while ago
that's like being read by everyone like
who cares now was not just a book is it
why are we talking about this he wrote
well because he's just flown in to see
his father yeah because his dad his own
brother his own brother refused to see
him and now you're doing a segment on on
bashing Harry like of course he doesn't
want to stay in of course he doesn't
want to stay in the UK whilst you're
bashing him on TV St out of here as well
absolutely I think he's brilliant I
think he's been honest with his journey
honest he lies for his back teeth no he
hasn't yes he has what are the lies list
them rep lies which ones he's been exp
he certainly wasn't lying in that court
case which court well the mirror court
case right exactly well okay you want to
talk about that not really but I'm
actually a lot of the things you're
saying aren't true he's not lying say
he's a liar he and his wife accus a ro
family of being racist that was a lie
there's no evidence for it never
produced any evidence for it caused
enormous damage to the royal family I
think it's despicable AA can you defend
Harry do you think he should be allowed
back into the bosom of his I mean I
could really care less about the Royals
to be honest altogether but which in
itself might be a problem for them right
because I think all this does is
diminish the stature of the monarchy the
more they're trashing each other the
more feuding and so on the L I think
that you know I think the people who've
got the hardest job to to to play for at
the moment are William and Kate because
they are going to be the eventual
successors and I think that you've got a
60% of the population now don't care for
the royalty don't really want to keep
funding it they're the people who got to
impress the rest of us would I be more
interested if they were engaging with
Prince Harry perhaps I might I might
start liking them again I don't know
about you I've said what I would do if
it was one of my family right I'm not
advocating that that should happen I'm
just saying if that was my family that's
what I'd feel like doing I would be that
angry right what do you feel about this
from a family point of view yeah I think
it's never mind the fact that he's
dashed all the way here to see his
father who's got cancer whereas Megan
hasn't once gone to see her own father
who's reported to be D so
unfair miles from her front
door you may not like it it's a
fact the thing I think it's difficult to
say what they should and shouldn't do
because I mean I know what I would do in
that situation but again people change
people can forgive but I think we have
to contextualize what William is
actually dealing with he has a wife
who's basically out of action he has
three young children he has to take on
more responsibilities you know and he
has to support his father and queen
Camila I can understand and he may have
to consider the possibility now and he's
probably Co region yeah well not just
maybe stepping in to do the duties if
the king capacitated or even if his
father's you know was to tragically die
from this cancer which could happen then
he would be a king in his early 40s
right I mean yeah with three young kids
which these it's a serious time for
William so I I appreciate that on the
his his top list of priorities is not
really being interested in extending an
all job by the way no but thing because
the thing is as well there's also the
concern what if Harry has Netflix
cameras taping every conversation that
they have where is the trust
as as I can understand that he has more
important things to do I personally I
mean I'm a Christian so you know I might
send him I might send him like a carrier
pigeon being like I still don't like you
but here you go all right let me bring
let me bring PE PE back in is that
Christian let me ask let me ask what do
you think of Megan Megan marle in all
this I I um I I think that sometimes
forgiveness is letting people lie in the
bed that they made you know if someone
you're refering to I I think if someone
robbed me if somebody robbed me I don't
have to let them back into my house I I
can forgive you but it doesn't mean I
have to keep dealing with you the idea
William should have to forgive brother
all he's done why should he no one said
he has to forgive his brother the thing
is as well what what where is this
definition of forgiveness where have you
got this definition of forgiveness from
what's your definition of forgiveness to
to let go of something that someone has
done not like you have to let them back
in your house
but something that someone has done
without absolving them of the
consequences of doing that I'm just I'm
absolutely forgive someone who rob you
can't be Baff I don't know why you're
asking about page of
every to the front page of every paper
is about this story why you Baff you
read the papers no the story is that
King Charles is unwell has cancer and
that we need to wish him our best
regards the story isn't oh Harry rushed
over why is there a news from BC telling
us William won't be seeing
Harry because actually it's quite
interesting that the young man who may
be king sooner than he would want to be
that his only sibling they don't they
hate each other so much they don't even
talk I do know for a fact can make the
case William certainly hates Harry for
what he's done I think you can make the
case har has um has stressed out his
father with the release of spare and all
of that and I don't I think it's a bit
ironic that he's rushing over to his
side when he's ill but he didn't really
care for his mental health when he was I
think that's up to them no I think
that's a fair point I think it's stupid
to to suggest you know what he hadou he
stayed in a
hotel Harry stayed in a hotel on this
trip I suggest next time giv your such a
fan he comes and stays with you he's
more than welcome of course he is and
also Megan I will roll out a red carpet
oh of course you would yeah of course
all Hypocrites STI together all right
thank you Pac and thank you Pearl across
there in America appreciate on Sor next
president President Biden tells trown he
recently spoke to the French president
miton who died in 1996 before then
forgetting the name of Hamas what is
going on in America who better to talk
to than Fox Fox news's comedy genius
Jimmy failer perhaps he can explain what
is happening in his country after the
break hey very good morning to you
thanks for joining us you're with talk
TV on TV on radio online and we're on
your smart speaking good morning Rosie
good morning Nick we're here in
turnworth for you to find out exactly
why some people are traveling halfway
around the world and queuing for hours
for one of these The Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense
it this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged AC crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbow carry on a horse crossbows like
a hatchet and what a sword and a knife
how is that even technically
possible we
going it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by S
Khan the mayor of London very rarely
meet anybody that says you know the
thing about London is it's got a great
mayor sadique Khan brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to Rishi sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with that
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a hundred criminal charges and yet all
that's done is actually make him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
that's the way it goes I did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel this was controlling
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions I've asked you two
questions should a master in power and
are they a terror group you're refusing
to answer either of them that is very
telling talk TV is the only place where
you get the truth you've done a book on
poetry poetry and music for the many I
love poetry we can agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to our sens I'm joined up
with a new host of Fox News Saturday
night the genius author of the new book
cancel culture dictionary and a is a
guide to winning the war on fun Jimmy
failer Jimmy great to have you on the
show I want to start by playing a little
clip of your president uh this week just
when you thought he couldn't get any
more
ridiculous there's been a
response
from the
uh the there's been a
response from the
opposition but
um yes I'm
sorry that was where he couldn't
remember anything uh he later then
talked about having spoken to the French
president meton who died in 1996 and
then he forgot the name of Hamas Jimmy
uh what is going on
now in Biden's defense Pierce The Press
has been asking him some really tough
questions lately like what is your
name what do you do for a living this is
a really sad thing to watch the worst
part about the Biden clip you showed in
regards to Hamas is a reporter actually
helps him out at one point he goes the
opposition and the Reporter Goes Hamas
meaning speed it up buddy we don't want
to be all day watching you fish here and
this is the reality of what we're faced
with with as a country like I don't make
this point as a conservative although
I'm clearly a conservative I make it as
an American we shouldn't have a
president who makes the sign language
interpreter shrug but that's what
happens when Biden speaks because from
time to time he makes up
words but they inter what the hell yeah
yeah you see the sign language
interpreter go from signing to like
Googling okay and that's my problem we
Pierce we have Aid presid you couldn't
play in Scrabble cuz you'd be fighting
the whole time it's not a word sir it's
not
AA is not a word I'm sorry Jimmy the
most inexplicable thing about this is
that Biden fully intends to stand again
in the election in November as the
Democrat nominee and thinks he can do
four more
years oh make no mistake about it Biden
has told everybody he knows he's going
to beat President
Reagan okay he's ready this is
the it's so then ring his friend
president meon to tell
him that's my it's the greatest thing in
the world because first he says meter of
Germany wrong then he says meter of when
I got inaugurated which by the way sadly
he died 25 years prior I mean this is
what I'm faced with as an American and
the reality is okay obviously the
Democratic party likes what we perceive
as a weakness because behind the scenes
they have a lot more power the
bureaucrats are obviously running the
Country Joe Biden is an iTunes user
agreement of a president they tell him
to scroll to the bottom and click I
agree you don't have to read it we're
just going to get rid of the border wall
old man scroll to the bottom click I
agree that's what this presidency is and
it's hard for me to watch because as an
American okay it's not normal to have my
president speak at the United Nations
and and they translate his speech to
English that's not normal I tell you
what isn't also normal uh Jimmy is
cancel culture driven by these woke
fascists who want to just eliminate
absolutely everybody for any
transgression you've written a brilliant
book the ATZ guide to winning the war on
fun we've only got about a minute but
what is the best way to combat this
culture well the truth is okay it's to
understand who cancel culture is they
existed before the social media age they
were always people who got mad at
comedians except we didn't call them
cancel culture we called them losers
okay the bottom line is the outrage mob
is not liked by either side they were
weaponized by the left for a long time
until they started to cannibalize their
own so what we ultimately just need to
do is get back to using sources of
escapism comedies music and movie for
common culture you can't let them make a
cultural Battleground out of the common
actually the whole point of the comedy
club is to leave it behind I think
you've hit it on the head damn them with
laughter laugh at them and laugh at them
and laugh at them until eventually they
become such a laughing stock that
nothing they say carries any Merit uh
Jimmy I can talk to you for hours you're
brilliant I love you I love your book
thank you for coming on on
sensitive my man thank you brother and
that's it for me whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored like Jimmy faer good
night
[Music]
hey very good morning to you thanks for
joining us you're with talk TV on TV on
radio online and we're on your smart
speaking what a happy start to Monday an
Arctic blast the royal family are up in
arms more problems with migration
welcome to Monday good morning Rosie
good morning Nick we're here in
turnworth for you to find out exactly
why some people are traveling Halfway
Around the World and queuing for hours
for one of these The Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense it no officer with your
level of training wakes up in the
morning and says what a great day to go
and shoot somebody this is done really
as the last result it's done in a
response emergency
response this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just outraged there's a way to deal
with knif crime right I mean okay it
doesn't deal with the underlying
problems in society and all the rest
that actually stops people getting
killed a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbow yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on crossbows and a
hatchet and what a sword and a knife how
is that even technically possible sorry
yeah I've got a microchip in my left
hand let's see can we can you hold it to
the camera so we can see where is it I
can't see yeah you can't see it cuz it's
actually inside the web of my hand
here where we going on show it's carry
on what just
happened was like brought to you by St
KH the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great May
it's a deep Cal brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely